au petit matin alex miles est
certainement l'un des seuls habitants du
quartier à être déjà devant sa télé les
yeux rivés sur la chaîne américaine cnn
ce partisan de la candidate démocrate
est inquiet après la caroline du nord et
l'idaho donald trump vient de remporter
la floride est extrêmement 9 du masseur
au téléphone tout à l'heure elle est
déprimée et prêts à new jersey c'est un
revers pour la démocratie
malgré cette première douche froide ce
partisan d'hillary clinton poursuit son
programme et livre ses premières
réactions à la radio sont continue de
parler une heure plus tard la messe est
dite sur les chaînes américaines donald
trump c'est son premier discours en tant
que président
initialement alex devait retrouver ses
amis expatriés dans ce bar dijonnais il
sera finalement tout seul
une ambiance plombée où le champagne
prévu a été remplacée par une soupe à la
grimace tout ce qu'il a montré jusqu'à
présent s'est divisée et recoller les
morceaux donc il faut vraiment faire des
choses importantes plus sociale et
c'est pas lui qui va le faire ni le
congrès dans le congrès et republicans
aussi qui est un avantage pour lui mais
qui est désastreux pour la suite des
événements aux états unis les amis
expatriés d'alex le long malgré tout pas
laisser tomber pour la plupart
abassourdi ils n'ont pu envoyer que des
sms de soutien aux allures de
condoléances